I was just show business that you're
someone phones you and says would you
like to be in the movie you say sure how
much and then they say the price and you
say that little all right and then you
do it ed Grimley ed Grimley was created
in second city in Toronto
I think first time and appeared on stage
was in 1977 but there was a scene I did
with Cathal Hara for the past several
years I've employed by the Union Oil
Company really in what capacity and I
work at about 76 at the corner of clang
of Melrose the captain was downstate at
one point I turned her Lakers and she
started laughing and the audience left
so suddenly it was like this it's very
decent to be here I must say then each
night I put a little grease in my hair
just to give the hair us an attitude or
something and then Peter accuracy just
said Marty you know your hair is
standing up more every performance she
was laughing about
so to make him laugh I put my hair in a
complete point and then the audience
laughed and then I thought wasn't that
the point of all this so I kept give me
a break I couldn't be more excited I
must say that character was very
prominent in my marriage so that if we
had a fight my wife and I she'd say I
don't want to talk to you anymore I want
to talk to Ed I like Ed better so I'd
then be come in and say oh what's his
problem Nancy talk about Self Indulgence
a month say I left second city in 1978
and never did it again until 1982 when I
joined sctv I wasn't sure if it would
work or not or if it was just too weird
for the room but you know I was in good
company with odd characters in that show
and he fit in beautifully I was an S et
from 1982 to 84 then in 84 I joined the
cast of Saturday Night Live for one year
I had this idea of putting him in Wheel
of Fortune as a contestant he went in
for his interview Christopher Guest was
the guy interviewing me why do you want
to be
tested on the wheel of fortune Oh cuz I
just I watch this show every day of my
life sir I just I think it's the best
show on the air ever that has been it's
weird how good it is it's so strange and
we just created a scene and it was a big
hit mr. Sajak I would like to buy a
vowel please and a face and on SNL if
you accidentally or stumble into
something that works they're saying do
it again so every you know third show I
do a new ed Grimley piece one time he
was going to be killed by Ed Asner
another time he was in love with Tina
Turner and it continued I was doing
Jimmy Fallon and Lauren just came down
said you want to do a cameo on the show
and I said okay because I often do that
Trump wasn't president then but he was
hosting but I never did you know
interact with the dear leader
Nathan Thurman Nathan therm would be
perfect for right now to be quite honest
a kind of defensive entity who keeps
changing the facts and then when
cornered attacks the person who is
asking the legitimate question remind
you of anybody we were doing a piece on
[Music]
satirizing 60 minutes
it was Billy Crystal Christopher Guest
Harry Shearer and myself we were writing
it I was going to play Nathan therm and
he was gonna be the defensive lawyer the
lawyer who represents the bad guys and
all those 60 minute pieces I didn't know
how to do it I didn't know how to play
it and the head of makeup that year was
a woman named Marion Siebert and she was
the most offensive human being you would
ever met she always changed mode you
could do that in 1984 and she said her
makeup charm you see look at me oh my
god none of your features match this is
tough for me this is hard work so
finally after 10 mins you say gee I look
a little pale don't I Miriam she'd say I
know that you don't think I know that
I'm I'm a makeup artist I wouldn't know
that so now it's a month later and we're
trying to write this piece and I don't
know how to play this
character Nathan Thurman I gotta play
and Billy Crystal said why did you do it
is Marian Siebert
you do her behind her back all the time
anyway and I said no but you'll find out
you he's out she won't know they never
know he said so I went down
of course forgetting that Marian would
be there on the set because she was the
head of makeup so as we did it take
harry shearer is playing um Mike Wallace
and he's saying about mr. Thurman your
client clearly broke the law and I'd say
I know that you don't think I know that
I'm a lawyer I would know that I know
that I know that and the director goes
cut he's sweating and marry me I know
that you don't think I know that I'm a
makeup artist I can see that and and she
never found out she never found out but
that was an example of a character
coming out of a person that you knew but
Nathan therm is what he would do is that
he would say something he'd be cornered
for having lied then he'd say you don't
think I know that I'm aware what I say
and I look at the camera see how boring
is he isn't he
low-energy over there right I do I'm
changing the subject because this is
boring he's a boring piece for doing
it's a good trick shysters use it three
amigos I had just finished a year on
Saturn at live I won't he had a one-year
contract it was interesting Billy
Crystal and Christopher guests and Harry
Shearer and I had a one-year contract
very unusual it had been a successful
year when you have some heat for my show
like that suddenly you know the movies
are interested and I wasn't sure what I
should do but then I got a call from
Lorne Michaels saying that they were
interested in me playing the third amigo
I went to Steve Martin's house in May of
85 to pick up a script I'd never met
they offered me the movie and I said
sure and then we started shooting in
January of 86 justice you will find us
wherever there is suffering we'll be
there fine
you know I was playing it kind of
naturally in the sense that there wasn't
a fake nose or bald pagers and if the
word satirize ation
for character development can be used
there it was tied to a type of person a
narcissist self-absorbed hence you know
there's a scene in that film where I'm
sitting on the stairs with a bunch of
little Mexican children discussing in
detail how I got started into my career
one time Dorothy Gish was visiting me on
the set of little Nettie grabbed your
gun Dorothy Gish not Lillian hick
complemented me and I knew that I had it
man you have got it
and I'd certainly was modeling it after
many narcissists that I had met in show
business and in life by the way
narcissism as we know is not restricted
to just show business actors others can
be narcissistic too
I can't think of anyone but I'm sure we
all know someone like that you know
someone who just needs it to be all
about themselves inner space
well inner space is my second movie I
play Jack Jack that was a really really
I thought terrific movie well directed
by Joe Dante great cast Dennis Quaid meg
Ryan and I played a kind of nervous
neurotic hypochondriac who worked in a
grocery store and in Berkeley gets
injected with a miniaturized Dennis
Quaid he's a kind of an astronaut he's
supposed to be injected into a rabbit
but the I will cut to the quick
he gets injected into me by accident and
suddenly he's talking to me
and I think I'm going crazy cuz I hear
voices I'm not out there I'm in here
here what
Dennis was there every day and he would
go into a little booth on the stage on
the sound set I always had an earwig so
he was he didn't have to go into makeup
need enough to shave but he would be in
his booth and he'd be doing the lines
and we were doing it all alive and then
of course his stuff was shot and then I
was off-camera three fugitives well that
was a very sad character
Frosty's maybe wrote a great french
director based on an idea of a guy who
has a little daughter and he's so
desperate that he tries to rob a bank
but he's totally now he ends up taking a
hostage nick nolte who was a criminal
and a bank robber and people the police
assume that Nick has robbed the bank and
taken me hostage but I have taken him
hostage I'm the hostage what do you say
and Nick was fantastic he was just the
sweetest nicest man no I'm very kind
great inspiration you know I remember he
had to play knocked out before he would
do it he would spin and get as dizzy as
he could be then lighting the camera so
that when the camera hit his eyes they
looked like eyes that were coming -
great great actor father of the bride
Frank was a character that was
interesting because the idea of Frank
was the audience that the owner
understand but they could also
understand why Steve Martin couldn't
understand oh please come with me and we
talked all about our he was so alienated
by the process of this wedding coming up
Diane Keaton and Kimberly Williams the
mother-daughter could understand Franck
but Steve couldn't so we had to figure
out a way to speak so that we could buy
that the ladies understood him that
Steve didn't but that the audience could
but could undress understand also why
Steve couldn't hasta - so we select a
keck first track more often the Thurman
what kind of watering that you end up
having so what we would do is we just
did a million takes some were improvised
and some we're not and I remember we
keep turning it down like a faucet like
it would be bad I brought back these
well that would be too broad no one can
understand it so we produce it and I
think the the secret character like that
is you can't try to be funny even though
he's as eccentric and odd and strange
and where is he from anyway if it looks
like I'm trying to be funny
it wouldn't be funny you have to kind of
be sincere within the madness of it all
I'll fall eight seconds behind US
consulate that'll be a big help I see
well as always great because everyone is
just in a great mood because they
already have a big hit under their belt
or there wouldn't be a sequel and also
there's not uncertainty you know even
when we were doing the first father the
bride understandably it was concerned
from the studio or from writer Nancy
Meyers and Charles Shire director not
concerned but but like wondering gee are
we is this weird to put something this
broad in the middle of something this
real and sincere but they went with
their gut and they they were right but
when you do a sequel and all those
worries and concerns are you know the
back burner you you could say Oh Franck
is over the top but I remember we
finished that movie and I went to a
wedding famous person's wedding and they
had a wedding coordinator that made
Franck look like you know Al Gore Mars
Attacks well that was exciting Mars
Attacks is very exciting you know I just
done a television special where I played
timber and I never met timber and I had
no idea whether he would be offended by
it or like it well it turned out he just
loved it and I think that helped his
decision in casting me as the press
secretary
nickels that was a really cool and
exciting experience just working with
Jack and Michael Fox and Pierce Brosnan
and Glenn Close and Rod Steiger you know
people were lining up the chairs with
the names of the back just taking
photographs because they couldn't
believe all these stars when one movie
and Jack couldn't have been nicer to me
he said when I first when I've had my
eye on you for many years
Jerry how soon can we go on the air well
it was just a very inventive
well-written script and very creative
and very ambitious the tone was always
interesting to figure out it was a
comedy but you couldn't look like you
were playing for Laughs you had to play
these people sincere you wouldn't
believe the pressure of my job nice to
see a face
tim is fantastic we've done a couple
films with each other after that people
think he's going to be like the Dark
genius and brooding odd he's just sweet
and friendly and laughing all the time
always laughs great sense humor Jiminy
Glick I was doing a talk show for King
World the mark short show and I wanted
to create a character an entertainment
reporter just so that we could go to
junkets and go out and get more
celebrities you know on the marquee as
we start to eat show by that time this
was now to 1999 had done a lot of
characters and earlier on in the season
of the Martin Short talk show I just
went to farmers market in Los Angeles
and I had a putty nose and I had a weird
wig and I just wanted to be serving fish
to people about using my hands and see
their reaction and everyone would say
hey time your autograph that's a drag
they knew it was me and I made a film in
1990 called pure luck on Danny Glover in
that film I was at one point stunned by
a bead had a an allergic reaction my
face blew up when I made that tell me my
wife visited assent said I don't I can't
see you in there I thought oh maybe
that's the look like a lot of latex have
you here and the jiminy good makeup
piece is just one piece and it just goes
here
it's your chin and then it goes to the
neck so it just moves on like that and
as far as who he was I was stuck in this
idea of a [ __ ] with power someone
totally inept but but a success he had
to be listened to so even though he was
a [ __ ] with power the power meant that
he had an assistant who would be nervous
as she screwed up his tuna fish order I
did not order salt in this and she had
to take it you know I don't know if you
can imagine a [ __ ] with power but they
do exist and they intimidating they're
mean to their staff it can be mean to
the press so um that was jiminy glick
and he would ask and like he said to Mel
Brooks what's your big beef with the
Nazis I was knocking the Nazis no that's
it's it's time for Mel Brooks to knock
tonight it seems so after the one year
mark short talk show which didn't
succeed so the following year I took
that black character and with the comic
central he interviewed everybody over
three years you know he said to Steven
Spielberg what are you gonna do the big
one what do you mean big one something
that clicks MacLeish for the public yeah
he had no knowledge of anything once
said to Edie Falco
yes can I ask you a question does not
mean I need an answer
that's self-indulgence Miffy and they
were just gonna take it you know but I
loved doing Jimmy Glynn because as
opposed to something like ed Grimley or
Nathan therm which was very written and
very specific and Jimmy is just
improvised we would do an interview for
15 minutes and then cut it down to six
but but back to the [ __ ] with power
idea is that if I send some of the
things that we would say about the
people on the screen as myself it would
be horrible but
if you do it as this lumbering character
minutes more innocent Dave Foley from
kids in the hall once said of jiminy
glick
you created a character who's actually
as mean as you are in real life the
Santa Claus 3 well Jack Frost was truly
evil he was an evil character that would
hide behind a charming smile like this
[Music]
you tie things back to the other line
that he was sinister he wanted to
replace Santa Claus
get rid of Christmas destroy all little
children's dreams of the 25th of
December he would mask it through charm
but sometimes his true self would flare
up you know we all know people who mask
evil comments with a smile spring and do
your elfin step I remember the Mary
Tyler Moore Show Betty White was
brilliant at that she played a character
Sue Ann Nivens and she was always saying
horrible things to Mary but under a real
sweet smile and oh I hope you don't take
this incorrectly but your life seems so
sad and dull anyway that's my
observation you know that Mulaney
Lou cannon was another narcissist a guy
who only assumed that everyone was
thinking about him worrying about his
success and his career I have an Emmy
Award and when you put it against this
mirror it's like I have two Emmy Awards
and that his career and the approval
from the audience was the most important
thing and he assumed was the most
important thing in everyone's life you
know his personal success those
characters are just kind of fun to play
because again back to narcissism this
idea that we're only thinking about you
and not our own lives becomes fodder for
comedy he and Jane Krakowski the
brilliant chain and they're the worst
parents of any sets of parents they're
just mad in love and they children
become an inconvenience no I have no
idea why I chose that voice but they
approved it you know what you do is when
you do a an animated movie like this the
first session they're really fun
animated movies because first of all
it's a different muscle I remember
making Frankenweenie in Tim Burton let's
say Marty can you do that line again but
with more of a smile and you say well
how do you do the smile that when you're
not being seen to smile but you can do
it you can do it like that you know just
kind of different loop I'd like to do
lots of takes and improvise animated
movies want you to do that so the first
session is you go in and you try a whole
bunch of voices and then everyone
listens to it and they say we like that
on British voice and I say I like that
too okay so now you pick the voice so
then you start you know playing with
that character unfortunately mother our
adventuring assumed to be over I think
the secret to all character work that no
matter how broad it is no matter how it
could be franck it has to have some
element in someone you've met in your
life or no to give it three dimension
you you pick up your cleaning in the guy
thing I couldn't get it stay on mr. John
and he's wearing the dress pants and has
a hairdo that's insane and he's not
trying to be a character or an SNL or
anything he's just existing in his life
so
many times the people that you meet if
you imagine them as characters you'll
say oh yeah I can see that
understand that so in life the
characters are out there broader than
anything you'd see again on SNL so thank
you very much GQ this journey examining
my iconic character then we left out
many of course we didn't talk about
Jackie Rogers and Irving Cohen but you
know there's too much time too long
career so thank you delighted to be
talking to you from a one-way view let's
stay strong and let's be wise and please
I beg of you listen to the scientists I
will keep trying to make you laugh if
you keep paying me